[Music]
most people know seth godin as a
marketing guru he has one of the most
popular business blogs and popular books
in the history of business plugs and
business books
Seth is known for his opinions about
entrepreneurship as well he's a huge
champion for the entrepreneur so I
wanted to ask him if entrepreneurship
has changed in this modern day but also
given the times that we're living in
Seth's wife Helene is also an
entrepreneur she quit her high-powered
legal job to start the by-the-way bakery
a gluten-free and dairy-free bakery in
New York City so we got them together to
talk about what it means to be an
entrepreneur in this modern day and
here's what they had to say
this is a bit of optimism ladies and
gentlemen I'd like to invite you to say
hello to the grand gluten-free Baker of
America lean Godin is in the house
Helene just so you know you're not late
early you are not late it is not
relative he can't stand the fact with
good reason that I am chronically late
so you're chronically on time he's early
I'm so glad we're doing this
and I thought what a wonderful thing
that we could talk about is
entrepreneurship and what it takes to be
an entrepreneur because both of you
entrepreneurs Seth a long time ago you
quit your job to start your own business
and Helene you were a high-powered
corporate attorney who also decided to
take the plunge and I'm very curious to
know because you both in on very
separate entrepreneurial journeys what
does it take to be an entrepreneur today
you go first
I'll go first entrepreneurship is not
simply a job it is a posture of
possibility and there are social
entrepreneurs who are building important
ventures that don't make any money and
what it means I think to be an
entrepreneur is to say I have something
to contribute there is no road map I
might have a compass but I want to show
up and try to make things better in a
way that a public that has a choice
could either choose or not choose and
entrepreneurs haven't changed every
corner of the world but a lot of what we
see in our built world in our modern
world that's better is better because
the human being showed up and built
something and I think you have to come
to entrepreneurship from a place of
generosity of saying what can I do to
make someone's life better and in my
case I loved being a lawyer and I think
most of my clients really liked me but I
wanted to go on a journey where I could
bring something tangible and sweet to
people and get tremendous joy every day
out of doing that and I have a tiny
little niche of people who happen to be
gluten free or dairy free but within my
niche I make them happy and that makes
me happy
I've always thought it was interesting I
think the term entrepreneur
entrepreneurship is thrown about a
little too loosely it's used
interchangeably very often with a small
business owner mmm-hmm and small
business owners owned small businesses
but entrepreneurs solve problems and you
have entrepreneurs and corporations they
don't all own small businesses and not
all small business owners are
entrepreneurs so I love your definition
Seth because I think that we have to
recognize that especially now there are
entrepreneurs trying to affect social
change they're trying to solve problems
in unique and novel ways you are correct
and I bend over backwards to talk about
freelancers not being entrepreneurs and
they should be proud of it
that being a freelancer is a job without
a boss and you can get better at it and
that's important and a small business
owner is a job without a boss and it's
also important but it is different than
the posture of the entrepreneur
internally if you work for a big company
I'm not quite ready to say you're an
entrepreneur as much as I might say
you're an independent thinking problem
solver because part of the theory of the
firm is that the corporation has given
you a platform and a safety net and that
changes the way you can approach them
yeah I guess what I don't want to give
up is that fear in the pit of your
stomach because you know you are
bringing something to a marketplace that
could just say no and having had that
happen to me so many times it's not the
fuel but
it's definitely the scary guardrail on
the edge of the cliff and I really love
this idea of the balance which is the
pit in your stomach which is everybody
wants the glory that an entrepreneur may
experience but nobody wants the pain and
I think entrepreneurs live balanced
lives like people who have corporate
stability live balanced lives like if
you work in a corporation your highs are
never that high but your lows are never
that low wherever you're an entrepreneur
your highs are amazingly high but holy
cow your lows are so low like both are
balanced in both equations you're gonna
live a balanced life the question is how
do you want your balance right and I
think that guess is two core idea of
optimism because unless you're
completely insane the only way to do
this is to expect the good things are
going to happen so let's change tact
very slightly and can you talk about the
importance in what entrepreneurship
looks like in a social setting
especially now there is a spotlight on
to create necessary change and so are
the entrepreneurs the leaders of the
black lives matter movement are they
buried within the black lives matter
movement like where are the
entrepreneurs and how do we support them
and get them to come out and do their
thing okay we are talking to each other
during a time of real pain real unrest
and renewed over do focus on injustice
and that black lives matter and that the
feeling that so many people are
wrestling with is real what we know is
that culture is the result of millions
of little things not what the media
announces is happening in any given
moment and cultural change sometimes
happens really fast and sometimes it
takes way too long
but it happens not from the bottom
that's the wrong word but from the roots
from the grassroots from people and the
question is where do the seeds get
planted and then what grows around them
and an example I'll give you is last
year more than a billion dollars when
into organizations that were building
enterprises to help the poorest people
in the world people make three or four
dollars a day well that only happened
because 20 years ago acumen
started doing something insane and the
social entrepreneurship of investing a
million dollars in delight solar
lanterns was on nobody's lips no one was
talking about it wasn't in the newspaper
and then overnight suddenly it's a thing
well it wasn't overnight right and so
social entrepreneurs say I can't fix
everything but maybe I could open a
craftsman guild in Pittsburgh maybe I
could figure out how to change the way
this nonprofit functions and then people
steal your idea and they steal your idea
and they steal your idea because after
it starts working a whole group of
people can feel safe saying well I'm
just gonna take that and make it a
little bit loud so does that mean a
successful entrepreneur is someone who
affects the change or creates a
marketplace you know steal your idea
steal your idea copy copy copy is what
is producing the change because people
perceive that there is a marketplace
like that is valuable that's worth doing
whether it's for financial gain or
social gain right so the people who
invented the internet are not the people
who run any company you've ever heard of
and Facebook wasn't the first social
network and neither was Friendster and
all the way back so entrepreneurs with
bad timing usually go first and if they
succeed corporations that have different
agendas can scale and I congratulate the
entrepreneurs even if they're not the
ones who are on the cover of the
magazine it's so funny because there is
there's there's I was gonna say there's
books and books filled with names but
there's actually not a single book
written with the names of the ones who
went first who were two complete
failures but were the the ignition where
the spark that somebody else ran with
from their vision their their invention
whatever it was and I know some of those
people and they're very frustrated
helene do you think you would have taken
the entrepreneurial plunge if you had
never known Seth no but I was always
very in the box in my drive like in
college I want to be a lawyer
because that's a defined thing and I
want to get really good grades cuz
there's a an easy metric and I want to
take every course that has and the law
in it because maybe that will help me
get in but through osmosis through
having the joy of being with the
man for so many years we just actually
three days ago celebrated our 34th
anniversary happy anniversary
you know but I have to disagree with you
on this I think that Helene was destined
to be a entrepreneur of some sort I
don't think she'd be running the largest
gluten-free Kraft bakery in the world
but I do think that Helene has always
looked at situations where she could
contribute and even if there wasn't a
engraved invitation decided to show up
and make it a little bit better and
that's just something that people find
and they can't get rid of and Helena's
had I have the good fortune that I have
a safety net that I've always had the
drive and the ambition but when you have
a partner who's there cheering you on
and when you have a high celebrating
with you and you have a low picking you
up that makes a huge difference so those
that disagrees with you what is it about
the marriage that you think gave you the
courage to jump knowing that he had my
back and I think that you don't need
that to be a successful entrepreneur but
it certainly makes it a sweeter journey
but I would argue that you do need that
to be a successful entrepreneur I've
always held this belief that courage is
not an internal fortitude you need to
dig down deep and find the courage you
know that courage is an external thing
the reason you have people have the
courage to jump out of the plane is
because the parachute on their back it's
the parachute that gave them the courage
or a world-famous trapeze artist would
never try a brand new death-defying act
for the first time without a net it was
the net that gave him the courage and
I've had the chance to meet men and
women in uniform who have actually
risked their lives to save the lives of
others they were not ordered to they
would not have been faulted if they
didn't they risk their lives with the
belief that they will probably die in
doing this action but they didn't and I
had the chance to ask them why did you
do it and almost to a tee they all say
because they would have done it for me
it was the belief that someone had their
back that gave them the courage to act
yeah I mean you've done really important
work in understanding the power of
uniform and the way the arms
services have you know the whole leaders
eat last mindset etc it's not the
parachute that gets someone to jump out
of the plane it's the fact that your
brothers and sisters are jumping out of
a plane before you and after you write I
think though we have to distinguish this
in the sense of entrepreneurs because
most successful entrepreneurs don't
actually think they're taking a risk go
on so what it means to think you're
taking a risk is that you don't have
control and you don't have an out and
what successful entrepreneurs do they
don't bet everything on read 32 what
they do is they are seeking to control
what looks uncontrollable to people in
the outside world and they are finding
bets that they have enough resilience to
survive if they're wrong and they are
showing up doing something that feels
way less risky than working at Ford
Motor Company because Ford Motor Company
once laid off ten thousand people in one
day and all 10,000 those people didn't
do one thing wrong except trust the
system and the at Renault looks at that
the one who grows up in Detroit and says
not me
maybe I'm just kind of a little more
danga doesn't matter it's mine and it
doesn't feel risky to me to do that so
this is interesting so that means then
that in this modern day and age because
we talked about the security of the
corporation which because of the overuse
of mass layoffs in this modern day mmm
that is actually far riskier to work in
a large corporation because it's not a
meritocracy if the company misses it's
arbitrary projection as you said the
next day you have no job through no
fault of your own so it's a full sense
of security just because the
organization happens to be large and
have a lot of money where as an
entrepreneur is if I lose my job first
of all it's totally within my control
and it's unlike a corporate job where
one day I'm employed and happy the next
day I didn't even realize I'm unemployed
whereas as an entrepreneur it really
doesn't happen overnight like that you
can kind of see it petering out so i
want to go back to social
entrepreneurship I want to understand
what a social entrepreneur looks like
and if it's different than a business
entrepreneur so one of
akiza's scale because social
entrepreneurship that you do in the
small is important but doesn't change
the culture enough so how do you get to
scale you get to scale in a couple ways
one way you can get to scale is you can
publish the PlayBook meaning you figure
out the cure to a disease and you
publish it in a journal and now lots and
lots of people can go to work doing it
the other way to do it is to figure out
how there's enough surplus created from
the intervention you're doing for you to
hire more people and so if I think about
the aravinda hospital the arvid Eye
Hospital has saved the eyesight of more
people in India than there are in LA
Chicago and New York put together total
and the deal when you get to Ireland is
you can either pay 130 dollars to have
your cataracts removed or 0 it's up to
you and you get exactly the same doctor
and what dr. V did in building Arvind
was he said how do I take the methods of
McDonald's and apply them to high
quality high throughput cataract surgery
and this would never have worked in a
non-profit organized hospital because
your goal there is deniability and
stability and dr. V is I'm willing to
fail not any given patient but in my
process on my way to figuring out how to
deliver this thing at a cost so that the
hundred and thirty dollar operations not
only pay for themselves but pay for the
free ones and he got good enough at it
that if you've ever had AI surgery in
the United States it was probably done
by an ophthalmologist who trained at
Aravind in India because in one day at a
New York Hospital you might do two or
three but if you go to aravindh you get
to do 18 and so you get better faster
and you get better patient feedback the
point is if you come to Government of
India
40 years ago and said we'd like to solve
a cataract problem what's the best way
to get 40 million people their eyesight
back this is probably not what they
would have suggested but because dr. V
had a scaling mindset he was able to do
this thing so can you be an entrepreneur
without a scaling mindset like what's
the definition of
right exactly that was the point is
scaling can happen if you are willing to
give up ownership and eagerly have
people copy what you're doing and that
is what the best social entrepreneurs do
so acumen who I've been working with for
twenty years early on started publishing
their successes and their failures so
that other people who are going to go
through this space don't have to repeat
their failure you know I look back at my
own journey and sort of I'm replaying
some of the decisions I made and there's
lots of people in my space who when they
have their PowerPoint or give their
speech they put a little TM at the end
of whatever the word is that they came
up with that basically it's all the same
thing and every ad agency is the same
thing like brand essence brand DNA you
know whatever it is it's all the same
thing and they will put a little TM on
it which basically says don't touch mine
and I made a decision in the very early
days that I was never gonna put a TM on
the concept of the golden circle or
start with why or even the concept of
why because I wanted other people to use
it
bingo and there's a reason it's spread
is because I didn't tell anybody that
they couldn't spread it well it also was
a really good idea beautifully presented
right and when permission marketing
showed up in the Oxford English
Dictionary that was a big win for me
because it meant I didn't have to work
as hard to get people to understand this
idea and you know Helene has done the
same thing the number of people who now
believe it is possible to help folks who
can't eat wheat has grown dramatically
because she showed him how to do it what
is the Oxford English dictionary's
definition of permission marketing I
don't know it by heart but it's
something like the concept of delivering
anticipated personal and relevant
messages to people who want to get them
that must be a source of unbelievable
pride that you honed this term that is
now part of the vernacular and the best
part is is the vast majority of people
who don't know it or discover it in the
dictionary because it doesn't say your
name in the dictionary yeah because as
you said you're okay with with other
people stealing it we've given you
preferrence
the reason I prefer it is I didn't set
out to corner the market I set out to
change the market and if I have to deal
with the fact that people think it's my
fault or it's not working right then
they call me and say what do you think
or can you fix this
it's like no I put this idea in the
world you should do with it the best you
can but I'm not owning it and that means
I'm not controlling it either well and I
think there's a certain push if you put
it out in the world and you make it
possible for others to try and replicate
and encourage people to replicate it
forces you to always be on your game to
always be the best you can as a leader
and as a colleague in the space so going
back to social entrepreneurship the
question is is how does somebody in a
social space create something that
inspires others to want to steal it and
do it and take over it and claim it as
their own right because social
entrepreneurs have the same egos and
insecurities as any kind of entrepreneur
which is we do want to be recognized for
the thing we did it's why we put TM on
everything except those who don't accept
those who don't I think the dynamic of
one group insisting another group do
something isn't often the way change
happens at a glacial galactic scale it's
more like in any given situation any
given individual finds that it's better
making a new decision with new
information not saying they were wrong
before it's better to do the other thing
but then what you do is you create this
dynamic and the dynamic is well so what
made my blog my blog the very first post
that really mattered is called the
Provincetown helmet insight it's gonna
waiting for the helmet story and so
Helene and I were in Cape Cod 400 years
ago and bike helmets were not that
common and there's a big network of bike
paths and I noticed because I noticed
things everyone on the bike path is a
couple and every couple is either both
wearing a helmet or need a person's
wearing a helmet everyone and I'm like
only two theories could be working here
people are attracted to people who have
similar helmet habits unlikely or
something's happening in the bike shop
so we went to the bike shop to watch and
I stood there for like ten minutes to
figure out what's going on and here's
what was happening you rent the bikes
you get up to the front of the line to
pay and then the person
the cash register says do you want
helmets and the two people look at each
other and every single time whoever
speaks first that's what they do first
person to speak that's what they do so
how do you get people to wear helmets
it's super simple the owner or the
person behind the cash register puts two
helmets on the counter and says what
helmets almost everyone takes them done
done because now the person who's going
to speak up and say no is taking a huge
risk and the same thing happened with
seat belts it took fifteen or twenty
years but that's exactly why
seat belts caught on not because you got
a ticket but because you converted
enough people that it was awkward to say
to them I I don't want to wear she
bought your whoops it was easier to just
put on a seat belt so what's the dynamic
then between legislation and grassroots
legislation usually follows the culture
by five years so interesting because I
think so many people try to affect
change quickly yep at the high level
versus in a sticky way at a grassroots
level correct and I think we see this in
companies even we see this in companies
all the time which is this company would
be so great if senior leadership would
just do this yep and I'm just gonna sit
here and wait for them to do that yeah
as opposed to me changing my own habits
knowing that this is the thing that I
want to do and I could just do it well
it's not just your habits because if you
just change your habits it's unlikely to
stick so when I was at spinnaker we were
the first people to do fancy educational
computer games for kids somehow I backed
into having 40 engineers sort of working
for me and a product line that if we
missed Christmas the company was in
really big trouble and I was 23 years
old I didn't know how to manage a
project I was doing everything I could
figure out and we only had a short
window of time and I went out and I got
a bunch of buttons there were 45 people
in the company I got 45 red buttons and
45 green buttons and I show up and it
was the all company meeting I said
here's what we got to do because we got
no time I'm not in charge of anyone in
this room I have no employees but here's
what I'd like everyone to do if you're
on the critical path and if your job
today requires you
working on this software that has to
ship please put on a green button and if
you're not but still doing important
work please put on a red button and
here's what I'd like to suggest if a
green person and a red person meet in
the hall the red person should say how
can I help and so I took a big risk but
we normalized a certain behavior for
three weeks in the organization and what
it meant was the chairman was getting
coffee for the junior programmer and he
could tolerate that for three weeks
because it was showing his status that
he could give up his status but the
point is if I had been waited for David
and Bill to do it it would have taken
too long but I said this is what it's
like around here we wear seatbelts and
we were buttons and you can do that with
a small group you have enough influence
to do it for six people and that is my
theory about why your TED talk was so
powerful because what you said was there
are five people in your department who
if you just showed them this short TED
talk and had a conversation about the
triangle and why things would go better
for you and for them and it was not a
difficult task because everyone had five
people in the company and they could do
that with and it didn't work because
they put you on the homepage of Ted it
worked because 100 people told 500 yeah
that's true
yep what does it take to stay married
for 34 years I think that has an
inordinate amount of patience both and I
would say you have an inordinately met
when I was we were both in college and
you know over time people grow together
or they grow apart
and I think we work really hard at
growing together so what does one have
to do to grow together it's not luck and
there's no wheel that you're spinning
that says AHA you guys are gonna grow
together congratulations
there's work that's involved here I
think that's a really important word
that most people who write for magazines
don't want to say if you decide that
you're gonna be an entrepreneur you
don't give up the first day it doesn't
work well and you don't spend a lot of
time daydreaming about when you're going
to work for Unilever you
a commitment to have the life you set
out to have and when you find somebody
special if you can figure out how to
make a commitment to say when it's hard
that's what's supposed to happen and now
it's a chance to do more work it's
different than what a lot of people get
taught which is it's not what you need
you should go try something else and
when I was growing up I didn't have the
role model of this is something you have
to work at and at first I wasn't so good
at this marriage thing and it is true
that like being an entrepreneur it's
work
so this worlds colliding here which is
the mentality of being a successful
entrepreneur which is the willingness to
keep added because you believe in it is
the same thing that is required to have
a successful relationship I love that
and I think this goes to the whole idea
that you know people talk about
work-life balance as if they're
completely separate worlds like we have
to find work-life balance you know the
only difference being work at home is
you know the clothes you wear in the
chair you sit on it's you they're not
different and these days they're exactly
the same exactly congratulations you
have work/life balance
same clothes same chair it's you like
the reason your friends love you is the
same reason your colleagues love you or
your clients level you it's you and if
you're showing up differently in one of
those two places than in one of those
two places you're lying which means all
of the stuff that we call upon to affect
change and the drive and the ambition
and the willingness to suffer through
hard times because we're fixated on our
vision is it sounds like all the same
stuff we need to bring to our
relationships because it's all us it's
all the same thing
the visions are different the work is
different but it's still work but it
still work in this day and age of social
media online dating it seems that unlike
in the past everyone needs to be really
good at marketing themselves mm-hmm like
we now all have a product to sell online
we all have to be really good at writing
body copy and headlines and we have to
be good art directors so that people
will find our product appealing where
before you just need it to be your
bumbling self and someone either find
that appealing or not and so does that
mean that there's a young generation
that are that
equipped to be entrepreneurs or you know
has this idea of self marketing helped
the bigger category of marketing or hurt
it what a juicy question well I think
that at some point the rubbers gonna hit
the road that like you may have the best
photoshopped photo on tinder but at some
point you have to meet the person and
present in real life and that's where
the true work comes in but there are
some people who are really good at
getting the date true but you don't get
the second date so you're talking about
marketing so my eyes lit up but here's
the deal there are two kinds of
marketing the one you just described as
hype and hustle and sizzle and the
surface and it's nothing I have truck
with in any area and that's what I keep
writing about the other kind is how many
true fans do you have and how many
people can't go to bed without talking
about how cool the thing you make is and
I'm just gonna guess that happier daters
and more successful people who are
seeking commitment are in the second
category that it is true that social
media expands your reach by a factor of
ten or hundred but I think it's also
true that circles of people who talk
about how irresistible Simon is it's
probably a better way to get a date than
having a better photoshopped picture but
there's risk associated you know the
hustle is lower risk correct the hustles
wrote lower risk but at some point you
get found out and you have to be your
very best or you hope that if I can just
get my foot in the door it's kind of
like a resume right it's like I'm gonna
tell them how wonderful I am and how
everybody loved me my former job and how
I was responsible for all these huge
budgets and all these product launches
because if I can just get the interview
then I'll show them that I'm great yeah
and I don't believe in resumes either
you know I think you're correct
if churn is fun for you this is the best
moment in the history of humanity but
it's not clear that churn leads to
long-term happiness okay did I ever tell
you the story about the person who was
down on their luck and was trying to
raise money in the short run versus how
to market Microsoft Helene if I told you
this story I
not hurt this time okay so when you see
someone who's down on their luck and
trying to raise a some money in the
short term they sit there on the side of
the street with a piece of advertising
there's a billboard that's a little you
know a little piece of cardboard and
they attempt to do the same thing as a
lot of bad marketing which is they talk
about themselves I'm homeless I'm hungry
I'm a veteran you know the whole list of
things to try and appeal to whatever
audience finds that thing appealing
which is no different than Microsoft or
any other company taking out a big
billboard that says more memory more
speed bigger screen cheaper it's just
all about me me me me me and so I found
a lovely woman who was down on her luck
who was willing to help me with this
experiment and I found out that what
someone's doing when they're sitting on
the side of the street with their
billboard is they're selling goodwill
there's an exchange of consideration
there which is if I put money in the cup
I feel good if I put no money in the cup
I either feel bad or I feel nothing in
other words I pay for that feeling of
goodwill so what they're actually
selling is goodwill and they're
attempting to sell goodwill by talking
about themselves and so I found out she
works for 8 to 10 hours sitting on the
same street corner and a good day of
selling goodwill she'll make between
twenty and thirty dollars said yeah I
changed her sign she agreed to use the
sign that I wrote for her and she made
$40 in two hours and the sign said the
sign said if you only give once a month
please think of me next time because we
went and asked people why don't you give
and we basically heard two answers I
can't give to everyone and the second
answer was how do I know they're
illegitimate how do I know they're not
faking it so we simply answered the
question